and I know that there are some people
they think that Islam and democracy are
contradictory these two don't go
together but Turkey is the nineties
Turkey the touch people the most most
majority they are Muslim and free to
practice what they believe and democracy
is functioning very well now as I said
we are aware our shortcomings definitely
there is no perfect democracy now where
there are problems heroes are there are
problems in America in in in Europe so
we have some problems but the main
principle of democracy is functioning in
Turkey turkey is a democratic secular
country and there's a freedom as I said
in my speech particularly since 2002 we
have been taking real reforms political
and economic reforms we are shaping the
country in a new times so that's why
turkey became a source of inspiration
for many other Muslims they are
questioning their leaders they are
saying that look Turkey's a Muslim
country and historically that was the
leading country the Islamic world once
we inherited our history legacy and our
identity is well known but at the same
time Turkey is negotiating for the full
membership with Europe EU turkey is the
part of European custom Union and the
democracy is getting the event even
again I mentioned in my speech that that
we are writing new constitution this new
constitution all the people that are
engaged all the NGOs all the
universities
whoever has something she has something
to say these are all listened to now the
committee is writing within this
direction so I'm sure that in near
future we will see more countries Muslim
identity Muslim population and democracy
is flourishing there also change the
world